my question is did he come Jesse came
it's it's just the fact that he was a
guy
[Music]
hey guys oh it's new dude that was so
sick hey guys
my neighbor that's like some crusty the
clown style so welcome you sounded like
those [ __ ] like uh uh keep it nice no
dude those [ __ ] in the mall you know
there's like people that try to sell you
[ __ ] like hey dude you wanna real quick
five minutes do you want to clear your
shoes the T-Mobile guys here's a Boost
Mobile phone for yeah the band the
balance man's hey guys do you use a
phone like get the [ __ ] out of here dude
oh right sounds great I'll go [ __ ]
myself thank you yeah go ahead uh
welcome back to another awesome episode
of the careful boys and we've got a cell
phone salesman over here Mr Jesus hey my
man come here you need some minutes you
literally you need some minutes remember
that the minutes how many minutes you
use man you look like you use like 100
minutes I got something for you oh so
you look like what you look like yeah
that's all they got like you look like
you talk a lot yeah you look like you
guys are roll over a minute that's what
I do I do Boost Mobile salesman that's
how you got me he's like yo mama made me
talk to you real quick you look like you
need like 200 minutes I'm like I mean I
use 200 men let me talk to you real
quick I'm gonna put you on a goddamn
plan all I [ __ ] need I was like
all right all right so do your Asian
accent I can't do a nation accent come
on dude
give me something give me something and
I'm just trying to mimic it give me
something the T-Mobile guy give me give
me a a an accent let me see if I can
Vietnamese Vietnamese well let me give
me here excuse me
excuse me
that's good bro excuse me I know we're
not sitting here I'm [ __ ] sitting
here watching the Japanese guy give a
Vietnamese attitude yeah I've been doing
it longer than you have oh [ __ ] put that
knife away no man you're not born from
it okay
how do you do that is it like a yeah
do they have a lot of men are you the
drinking the waters
oh that's good that's good
no I can't do it I can't do it that's
[ __ ] race that's racist
which one's a Cambodian though
I think a lot of the South Southeast
Asians kind of have a little bit of the
the good
it was Cambodian but yeah he'll talk
black like [ __ ] [ __ ] don't know
[ __ ] ain't gonna talk to his mom yeah
sonic Hood as [ __ ] ain't sounded
confusing me speaking of when you're
joking you were just talking about oh
dude I got a crazy [ __ ] story tell me
the detail okay I'll tell you to detail
[Laughter]
don't get me started dude I'm gonna get
me started dude I had a homie this
happened to him dude I'm not gonna say
his name because poor [ __ ] guy dude
but my friend right now okay
[Laughter]
you gotta believe that a minute three
anyways leave that now but he actually
uh hooked up with this he hooked up with
this girl right really hot dude what's
her name I'll show you two returns and
I'll show you her picture [ __ ] it so he
hooked up with this girl right the club
everything was great he [ __ ] hooked
up she's hot whatever and then later he
finds out that this girl was actually uh
trans and she transitioned to a woman so
she was a guy before but never told him
but what do you mean hook up like that
they [ __ ]
they [ __ ] did what he did oh all that
dude he couldn't tell the difference so
I guess he didn't they were drunk I
don't know he had a condom didn't really
tell us whatever they [ __ ] I don't
know but they [ __ ] and I was like bro
did you I I [ __ ] and I was like damn
but he later found out that she was
trans he was embarrassed to talk about
it and really [ __ ] with him he was
angry about it but then she came at him
like yo you're being transphobic
for getting bothered by it and it's like
so my thing is
how would you feel and is she right or
how we feeling about this what's going
on with this is that like I think it's
kind of a [ __ ] up thing to do if
you're not gonna tell someone but then I
think she felt like why should I tell
you yeah but it's like but technically
it's like yeah well I don't like guys
that's why but but I don't know maybe
that's why I don't like eyes maybe
that's why I usually she's like you're
not a guy exactly but that's the thing
but she okay oh then now we get me into
[ __ ] Rocky [ __ ] ways
dude and this Captain does not know how
to steer this [ __ ] dude
[Applause]
I just rode a boat you know what I mean
my question is did he come Jesse came
then what is he complaining about yeah
exactly it's just the fact that he was a
guy oh my gosh she's a female but it's a
guy semen I mean a guy this guy guy
[ __ ] um he's a rocky waters for sure
this is Deadliest catchment hey dude
minute five discretion dude hey guys
scratch it off forget I even said
anything dude but I'm saying is it
technically is the DNA is it still male
like like saliva
though
because here's the thing is like if I'm
going in for a hookup and I got what I
wanted and it was great
who [ __ ] cares but what if his thing
is like I don't like trans girls then he
[ __ ] up yeah but but wife like she
never said anything like he didn't know
like is he supposed to ask hey why wait
I don't know you were trying so to play
Devil's Advocate
the fact that he didn't know kind of
like double as Advocate to himself
because if he goes well I don't like
trans women well the fact that he came
and he enjoyed that experience
something different he came he came he
saw and he called yeah dude I was like
tripping out he showed me the girl I
slid you up and the thing
I was like holy [ __ ] that's a girl yeah
well I have to agree because as far as
he knows till the end she was a woman
and he was having sex with the woman
exactly
I don't know it's to me it's like it's
not like he showed up and then she had a
dick and he and he's like well I suck
don't say names though
share with the clown I want to see okay
hold on guys
how come he gets to see how come wait I
mean some of these give it a second look
for the reaction don't be in the corner
cam guys they want to see your reactions
that's that's a woman dude they can't
see some of these trans girls are better
than some real women yeah no I mean
that's who it is fair enough I mean they
got that thing yeah but it's got the one
though yes
[Laughter]
yeah there's there's a thing there
there's there's bottom pieces there's a
thing to [ __ ]
so then apparently it looked and felt
great right like dude listen he wouldn't
have known listen how did he find out he
was just like she told us yo what the
like he was just very like yo what the
[ __ ] like I don't know how I feel about
it and then he was just like yo yeah
you're like [ __ ] and then he started
like really feeling like kind of like am
I gay he felt like
like he was used or not used but he just
felt like very like lied to I think
that's what [ __ ] him up but he's not
going into a relationship bruh but the
fact that but the fact that you're
the fact that you're like
trying to like have sex with a girl and
then you find out that well technically
it's not really a but but the thing is
that he didn't even know yeah because
because to her he didn't even know she
was a trans woman yeah yeah yeah
but that's the thing that's him being
transphobic that's that's the argument
here right because why is the triple but
that's what you like if you don't like
what you like that's a preference I
think what's wrong with him not liking
what he likes yeah so so I think the
question is the question is should trans
people so so access granted so access
correct access granted access granted
the question is should trans people ex
like disclose disclose before they get
laid and is that the moral right or
wrong that's that's a question I think
you're trying to I think that's what I'm
trying to say and yeah
I think it works uh it's a double-edged
start for both sides number one right
yeah uh
from his point of view it's like she
didn't even have to tell him right she
could just she don't have to tell him
yeah you know what I'm saying that's
true and that's it and so if you bust it
or not it's like he don't if he never
knew that's it if she wants to tell him
then she needs to understand that we're
in a more sensitive time than what his
ideal is all in the same way that's like
you're absolutely right that would be
transphobic or like even to be like oh
no I don't have sex with a transgender
woman like that I can understand how
that's viewed as transphobic right I
just think that we're in that time of
transition where people are learning
these things and finally understanding
things like terminology uh what you
identify with it like the world society
is becoming sensitive to these things
where like a year ago two years ago it
would be a lot more close-minded you
know what I'm saying I mean I just think
you have to be sensitive to the times is
all you can't just be like hey we had
sex and it was great but guess what I
used to be a man like that's gonna [ __ ]
a dude up you know in today's time I
have one yeah if you were at the club
and you met a shorty and you [ __ ]
what would you like would you like them
to tell you or would you just be like I
don't want to know well here's the thing
right if he did if he had no idea I'm
asking you I know I'm saying if I had no
idea
then it's all good then you've later
found out but then again it's like but
you later found out would you be a
little like it's like the ignorance
Bliss yeah right 100. I understand but
if you find out right you wouldn't you
be like um
how do I feel about this
and I'll be honest like she looks like a
lady I would I would like okay
I I would like for at least to be like
hey by the way you know I'm trying for
me to be like you know what
[ __ ] it you know what I mean let me give
me the truth you would like that but at
the same time
what happens when that person is like
hey by the way I gotta let you know on
this and then you're like oh dude but
it's enough but it's a normal human
reaction for me to be like let me figure
let me process this too yeah right give
me give me some normalcy for me to be
like yo this is new to me let me figure
out what to do here because that's
normal too I think it's both though I
mean like there's your
books
yeah I think like both like arguments
can be valid to like a certain extent
but the thing is is that like if your
friend saw her as a woman and thought
that she was a woman and that was like
initial like you know that's essentially
like how she feels and who she
identifies with and like she actually
went through the means of transitioning
and changing her body and doing
surgeries and stuff like that only to be
just the mean to the point of like no
you're a male first you know it's kind
of like you're telling somebody who
feels like they're a woman who
identifies as a woman saying you're not
a woman at all got you and who looks
like a banging ass don't get me wrong
she's [ __ ] hot if I was I would have
been like I don't want to know yeah if
you creeping keep it on alone
shut up shut up lady that's what she
should have done this is what she should
have done she should have been like this
you know what I mean she shouldn't have
said [ __ ] yeah she should have said you
know if if he was coming onto it and if
things were mutually and consensually
like you know maybe at the club it's all
dark maybe it's like starting to like
make out feel each other's Goods show
him you know if I'm her show him that I
got a vagina if he's playing get him
hard once she's jacking my bill hey by
the way I used to be a man I'm in
transition but I know that you're hard
and you're down for this and I have a
vagina you cool
that's Rocky water you got a vagina
you want to do this but that again as a
trans woman though I'm sure in her mind
there's like the sense of always in the
back of her head like like he won't hook
up with me not even that but like the
violence part because that's a real
issue too right it's [ __ ] me up after
no but she might [ __ ] him up or the
feeling of like why do I have to keep
reliving this stuff
but I think I think it's both okay like
if the dude doesn't feel necessarily
comfortable with being a trans woman or
or or not preferring a trans woman
that's his right too but it's also like
I don't know is it okay for her I'm
still more like why did he tell why did
she tell me why did you come unless she
wanted more in the relationship is all
you know what I'm saying because if it's
like if it was just a hookup I'd be like
[ __ ] it don't even mention right so
that's a valid point so like what if she
never said anything and they've been
dating for three years I'd be pissed any
line of relationship is is annoying yeah
yeah if you want to continue the journey
I need to know the truth you know what I
mean because then that would be the
question of like could you guys have
kids right or like what's important
between the two I don't know I think I
just think it's like a little uh Rocky
situation where it's like you know she
has a the thing about like she has a
right to like not say anything but it's
like when did I lose my right to get
upset about it how do we give that right
but then we lose ours well here's the
thing have the right to be upset too you
can you can yes right so like but if you
identify as a straight male and you fell
in love with a woman and she identifies
as a woman how is that being gay no
because it's his definition of male and
female is not the same as yours right so
then if his definition is not the same
that doesn't make him transphobic that
makes it like hey I'm trying to date a
birth female that's like religion so I
get that if if he likes strawberry ice
cream don't you know don't make him get
yeah they'll give you vanilla I want ice
cream that's the that's the argument
strawberry dye on it but that's that's
the thing though he'd even [ __ ] I get
what you say I hear yeah and I I think
you're right and then it's like both
parties are right that's why I'm very
like that's why his topic to me is very
interesting because I was trying to tell
him like well
did you have fun yeah because she looks
hot and if you don't like it give me the
number right now
there's a lot of straight guys that
would hit it a lot of straight guys yes
she looks hotter than a lot of women
yeah if she would have told me if I
could yeah by the way I'm trans I'd be
like
so it's like my thing but I hear what
you're saying I understand what you're
saying so that's why it's a really weird
situation and I don't understand I don't
know what to tell him so I was like oh
that's why it's talking to me what's the
update how's he feeling about it he he's
like right now they're yeah they're
[ __ ] getting married no he he's still
like really bothered by it and he's more
Angry he's angry he's angry he's more
like he's like what the like like he
wanted he told me which made sense to me
he said but give me the right to say yes
or no yeah that's all I want give me the
option to be like hey dude like if
that's the case give me the information
and let me make a human decision to be
like yeah I'm feeling it it's cool like
but I'm not feeling that I'm not
comfortable with that yeah let him be
have the right to say no I'm not
comfortable best case scenario that's
like starting off like any kind of
relationship if it's just a hookup I
guess the rules are of Engagement are a
little bit different so he says that
yeah it's the line that [ __ ] him up
right but let's say they wanted to even
pursue a relationship it's like okay
well you already started with a lack of
transparency trust and respect of giving
somebody the option of but is that right
is that right I don't know if it's the
thing I don't know if it's right I think
it's all I mean you know if I were I
don't know if that's the right question
if it's right or not I think yeah I
think it's just it's really gray area
right because if she fully transitioned
as a female then she is solely a female
right I think like so like that's one
side of the argument right and then the
other side is like your friend is
questioning now his sexuality right
because the fact that he fell for a
person who he felt like was a full-on
female but wasn't a full-on female in
his definition right but like she sees
herself as a female then at this point
it's like well you were attracted to me
because you thought that I was a female
right like your assumption right like
because I am a female right and then now
that you're mad at me because I
transitioned to be the person who I've
always felt like I was and so I was like
why do I always have to tell you as a
straight person like you someone who
died identifies as a straight like
you're also dating a female so that
makes you also straight so it's kind of
like that's like why why are you
entitled for me to tell you that
information but then but then but then
also the other part of it too okay so
what could what if he wants to have a
kid right right so then at that point
then you would have the discussion
do you feel like he was questioning his
sexuality or was it just was it more of
the the being upfront with well yeah I
think I think because this is a new
thing and he was put in like a situation
where now he's thinking like well what
is this is this what I'm trying he's
trying to figure out what what did I
just do did I do something gay did I do
something normal so it is what am I
putting where do I put myself in so what
category am I and that [ __ ] him up and
he's like and that's [ __ ] up that now
I have to live like that I have to live
with figuring out what happened but you
don't have his perception is his reality
and the reality that was presented to
him was a woman so I don't think he's
gay in that perception I think to a
certain I'm still more like why did why
did women tell him is all that's what
I'm still working I think that's the
main concern is it like should people
disclose or not disclose before hooking
up yeah that is because that's where I'm
torn on because like is it
and for what reason right because like I
said for a relationship I would want
people to disclose most things yeah
right but for a hookup I'm totally fine
if if if it was a hookup and I was going
in for just physical and I thought they
were beautiful and I just wanted to do
it and afterwards I found out that
they're born a man I'm like well that
was a good lay yeah you know what I mean
it doesn't [ __ ] with me but I can
understand how it can [ __ ] with someone
else because not everyone has the same
definition of reality yeah his idea of
male and female and who he's supposed to
have sex with maybe it goes against his
religion or whatever we have to consider
all those things because for me I might
be okay but for his buddy like that's
what he's going through right now or or
take like trans out of the picture
imagine like you like meet somebody at
the bar you hook up and stuff like that
and then after you're done having sex
they like put on their wedding ring
they're like oh that was sick so we're
talking about we're talking about the
emotional connection opposed to the
physical connections I think that's the
debate just to even like do that it's
like would you that's true the knowledge
alone the thing that like puts you in
kind of like that slight pair because
you still felt good and you hooked up I
would ask him I guess that question
instead of trying to give him advice I
mean this is poor guy he's gonna watch
this and he's like [ __ ] why did you have
to tell the question I was like what was
your intention for a physical attraction
or for an emotional connection no for
sure it was a [ __ ] for sure he's hooking
up it's easier to I guess dismiss in
that way but but but I think that's the
world that we're living in now and it
was just one of those things where I was
like [ __ ] dude I don't know what to do
here and I don't know what's right or
wrong because I'm also with the whole
thing I was like dude
it was to me it was yeah I was a girl
you hooked up with like you know but at
the same time I can understand what he's
questioning what he's going through with
that and I thought that was pretty
[ __ ] up that you know he has to live
with that and of him trying to figure
things out like you know like it's
almost like he was he was rushed into it
instead of like he was presented yeah so
he was if he asked if he was asked like
um hey would you like to sleep with me
because you know so I'm I'm actually not
born whatever and they had that
conversation he was still like you know
what let's [ __ ] roll then he his mind
is more prepared exactly so I think
that's what he was more angry about he
wants the lack of choice yeah he wants
the fact that he wants to have a choice
to be like yes or no that's all I feel
like it's it's those cases where it
really varies between like different
like transgender people where whether
they want to disclose it or not like
some will some will probably do it and
some probably will never do it right
because they don't identify as that so
do you think that's [ __ ] up or do you
think that's okay I think it's their
choice I think it's the context again if
you're like hooking up that's different
if you're like if I'm like swiping on
you on hinge looking for love in a
relationship and children and you don't
disclose that stuff that's the context
you know what I mean like yeah but when
I remember when I was out here on
Twitter like I have a Twitter I mean
[ __ ] a Tinder yeah
but I remember the girls would be
straight up and be like oh by the way I
just let you know I'm trans woman I'm
like oh [ __ ] yeah well I'll see you
later playing but not but you know it
was one of those things all right but
you appreciate that too sir yes and I
did though I did appreciate I was like
yo because I was you're like oh thank
you for giving me the choice yeah right
I didn't [ __ ] type this
but I yeah so it was one of those things
where I was like hey she [ __ ] let me
know I had the right to say yes or no
you know let us know in the comments
what you yeah what do you guys think but
if you're gonna be discriminatory don't
say that
foreign